at least once a year i like to bring in
some of my kevin's
famous chili the trick is
to undercook the onions everybody is
going to get to know each other
in the pot i'm serious about this stuff
i'm up the night before pressing garlic
and dicing whole tomatoes
i toast my own ancho chilies
it's a recipe passed down from malone's
for generations
it's probably the thing i do best
so while they repaint the lines in the
parking lot we're asking everyone to do
street parking i'm not street parking my
mercedes well everyone is i'm doing
it cause nobody wants to steal a saturn
all right uh moving on to recycling
you okay ron just a little tooth pain
i'm fine
continue okay each department will be
getting blue bins
do you need to go to the dentist ron i
don't like dentists
just a second hey no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no
[Music]
oh my god i'm sorry everybody what were
we talking about
recycling dentist pulled the tooth out
yesterday
but it's always a good idea to
demonstrate to your co-workers that you
are capable of withstanding a tremendous
amount of
pain plus it's always fun to see tom
faint
so do you recognize any of these men i
was hiding in the bathroom stall so i
didn't see his face
but i heard him he was singing along to
the music at the bar do you remember
what he was singing i think it was that
song
i want it that way backstreet boys i'm
familiar okay
number one could you please sing the
opening to i want it that way really
okay you are
my fire
number two keep it going the one desire
number three believe when
i say number four i
wanted that away
tell me why ain't nothing but a
heartache
tell me why ain't nothing but a mistake
now number five i never wanna hear
you say
ah chills literal chills it was number
five
number five killed my brother oh my god
i forgot about that part
are you swallowing them whole you're
eating them so fast are they even
touching your tongue
yeah why aren't you having any angela oh
i ate so many already when no one's
looking
yeah right my baby's dieting
she wants to fit into a special
child-sized wedding gown for our big day
why do those exist it's from my pageant
days i was miss tiny mid-atlantic bride
when i was 10.
probably heard of it brownies is that
pastry cubes made of sugar and fat no
thank you i'll stick with my jerky
so why'd you come in here to socialize
and then form ooh
brownies i'm taking two so i can parcel
them up
and eat them at my leisure later on much
healthier
you taking two yeah um but one of them
is for tubby
yeah why don't you send that to him in
costa rica
um i'm just gonna hand it to him right
now okay
weirdo why is that why is that weird she
said she was gonna give it to him right
now
she's probably going to because they sit
next to each other yeah they used to
toby works here again oh can you imagine
oh no oh you don't know i don't know
what you should probably just meander
back there take a look
see if he's if he's back dare i
you know what i'm going to for old times
sake
great practical joke jim got me go to
the annex
no god no
god please no no no
[Music]
no
i found this typewriter next to the
courtyard dumpster
an old underwood five with original
carriage return
took her home polished her up and bought
a brand new ribbon off of
electronicbay.com
okay somebody's gotta do something i'm
getting a cluster headache
oh robot he's leaving let's go
i'm gonna throw it away no i'm not it
weighs a billion tons
what is he typing anyway if you sons of
[ __ ] try to remove this typewriter
i'll kill you
i'm gonna type every word i know
rectangle america
megaphone monday
butthole hey there boyle how was your
weekend
well actually i got a little sick oh
really i'm sorry to hear that man
yeah bullets over broadway was on tv i
came down with a big old diane
weast infection
like yeast 20 20. uh that's a stretch
fine 20-24 i win
we move in there i'll take the west wing
you take the east wing you can be the
first gentleman
actually that sounds kind of great
thanks for coming with me to get my
stuff
how can i pass up an opportunity to look
at our future house
oh just remembered i i kind of got you
an engagement present
is it a waffle tower i mean it's a
little better than that
quality welders
how did how did you do this called in a
few favors
excuse me a few hundred favors mr vice
president
ben wyatt from congressman murray's
office and dave told me you're gonna be
coming by and you must be leslie knope
welcome
welcome
my name just came out of your mouth well
yeah it did
this isn't happening this this isn't
real no it's it's happening
and i'm delighted to have you here on
behalf of the president myself
oh mr vice president i am deeply
flattered but there's no way that i
could take over madam secretary
clinton's position
i mean i'm confident you could do that
job or any other but okay we will
well the reason you're here is i'm told
you've done such a great job
in your town and the state of indiana
and i just want to say congratulations
for your public service
i just want to say thank you well you
you're very welcome you're very welcome
hey you're you're very welcome you're
you're very handsome i think we're all
done well you're very nice but thank you
thank you thank you very much thank you
very much we'll see you tomorrow well
oh well you will thank you mr vice
president
you're welcome you don't let anything
happen to him do you understand me
he is precious cargo no
no no no no no no no no no no
nobody can do this
[Applause]
you're falling behind
[Music]
this is how you make it in this country
nobody
[Music]
[Music]
go
no no no no no
that's crazy
[Music]
[Applause]
toby how did we do well that was better
you